[Musique]
je suis mal à rabat si j'ai 20 ans je
prépare un master en management
d'affaires en alternant shaiya speed
j'occupe le poste de responsable
partenariats
[Musique]
et à ce prix c'est une société qui
commercialise une application donc qui
permet de mettre en relation des
professionnels du sport avec des
particuliers mam et son principal sava
d'entretenir les relations avec les
partenariats spees quotidiennement ça va
être des appels des prises de rendez
vous avec des personnes des coachs ou
des associations des salles de sport qui
peuvent être intéressés par notre
concept
[Musique]
je me suis plusieurs fois retrouvé dans
des situations où cette application
aurait pu m'aider
ce qui est bien dans le fait d'intégrer
une star paix plutôt qu'un grand groupe
sais que je peux faire preuve de
créativité et d'initiative au quotidien
c'est vrai que l'instabilité d'une start
up pourrait plus m'inquiéter
mais la mission qu'on m'a confié me
challenge et me donne personnellement en
vie de dédé a développé cette ce projet
le fait que le projet son appel lancé
moi ça me donne envie de me construire
avec et de le voir grandir en fait tous
les jours
[Musique]
l'avant page principale du fait d'être
en alternance est de pouvoir mettre en
pratique mes connaissances dans des
tâches quotidiennes concrètes
mon rythme c'est d'une semaine par mois
à l'école et trois semaines par mois en
entreprise
donc je peux être pleinement investi
dans mon post
[Musique]